so next round I definitely have to
play a little faster game
so this time an opponent from Puerto Rico
B3 well okay the game I
usually always play like that somehow quite
stock songs
aha
g4h4 at least that's what it looks like but
maybe the strange move wants to play that too  back then
5,
well, I still have
C7 now, but let
's make my field for the
bishop if he really plays G4,
okay let's
develop it further first,
so let's see, but the knight that
can really hold permanently is now
also done by the G4 for a short time  has
respect, well, I think I only have 7.
I would have assumed that the
move wasn't playable at all, well hg5,
so now it just hangs E5,
yes, okay, that just wins material and
he no longer has any king position at all,
so now you can  Of course, just
play GF and first have something more. There
is still a better move. Spoon
E4 or something like that,
you can take it first. The
opponent is actually committing
a kind of suicide.
Wherever I go, I'll go to the
seven
later, maybe then continue to F6,
so that's how
it looks  It's sensible to put it in there first,
so
make the rook fleet and the
Jack the chess can't be completely wrong,
so now we still need the knight
because he would like to go to E4,
but building the bishop with F5 does
n't make a good impression either.
I'll go first  to B8 so I
can take CD with CD again
so he prepares that
okay I'll go out now
maybe I now have the
opportunity to draw runner D3
yes and then F5 and then I run here
that looks good
okay then I have  didn't see it, which
is of course kind of embarrassing,
okay back again, yes it doesn't help,
I have to bring the knight to E4
no matter how the bishop is then
I have to capture it anyway and
then the bishop on G6 becomes active again,
spoon H5 also comes into consideration
I just see that
then he will probably be
okay, I have to serve that first, I
'll stay on H2
yeah yeah okay, so that's not dangerous at the moment
I'll take it easy 5
now it actually looks like that but
runner goes two games would have to be with them
He probably won't be able to allow an exchange
then knight E4 comes straight away
and bishop goes two
okay he says he can get the exchange
then we'll
bring the thing to E4
so it must be broken somehow now
so well bring the queen over  after
G7 for example
so okay
so so that G4 with the idea of ​​Queen H3 or
Tom H2 looks good
and yes that represents F3
1 but
that was bare in the game by white